you've probably seen a ton of s like
this before
maybe you sat through a webinar and
you're on the edge on whether or not to
buy one of these digital marketing
agency courses I was one of them and so
was my business partner and we were just
drooling over the idea of just having a
few clients pay us a ridiculous retainer
every month for running what seemed to
be a few simple Facebook ads well after
months and months of failure we decided
to finally throw in the towel and close
the doors this is what we learned
I was always a little bit apprehensive
about sharing this online because we did
fail but you know what you learned the
most from failures and even better when
the failures aren't yours when social
media marketing agency started to become
popular back in 2014-2015 it was a good
opportunity business owners were
completely new to marketing on social
platforms so it was easy for agency
owners to get their foot in the door and
land clients whether you were good at it
or not but there lies the problem
because if you think about yourself
you're probably interested in doing this
to make money not because you're
passionate about running Facebook ads
for the rest of your life
heck people dedicate their lives to
mastering ads and these would be agency
owners are reaching out to hundreds of
local businesses each and every day and
charging business owners a ton of money
when all they've done is watch a few
videos in a course and have zero
experience whatsoever so what happens
you have people trying to take thirteen
thousand dollars from business owners
and then they go on Facebook to ash
strangers for help and then they don't
get the business owners any results and
then they lose the client and then you
ruin your trust and reputation with that
business owner and everyone in their
network and then you move on to the next
business owner and the cycle repeats yes
this happens often and yes it happened
to us and what happens to all of these
business owners that fire the social
media marketing agency that they were
working with they're gonna be very angry
with you they're gonna feel like they've
been scammed and they're gonna associate
digital marketers with scammers now
repeat the cycle thousands of times
around the country for years and years
and years until we get to the day and
nearly all small businesses have been
screwed by digital markers in the past
and have no interest in working with any
other ones in the future this is the
market you'd be getting yourself into
all the business owners you be targeting
have been screwed there's more
competition than ever because these
courses have been around for years and
there's just more popping up every
single day and you're here the complete
beginner
which brings me to my next point that I
touched on briefly you actually need to
be good at the ads you'll be running
which is pretty hard see marketing
advertising and writing sales copy for
that as themselves is a completely
separate skill to master or at least get
adequate at if you actually want to get
business owners any results which you
should want to get some results because
if you don't you would lose that client
on top of lat each advertising platform
Facebook Google and YouTube are all
completely different from each other and
each one requires its own dedicated time
and experience to get good at and on top
of that you'll also be learning how to
prospect clients how to close clients
how to run your agency and it ends up
being this giant cluster of skills that
you have to learn all at the same time
and while you're struggling through all
lists you're gonna keep seeing
testimonials of successful students that
grew their agency to like $10,000 per
month twenty thousand dollars per month
in only three months and you're gonna
look at yourself like man I really suck
why can't I do it if he can do it but
little do you know that the internet
marketers selling these courses usually
like to stretch the truth of the
students results to sell more courses so
there's really high competition and the
lowest Amann ever digital marketers have
a horrible reputation with business
owners and you have to learn way too
many skills at once to be successful so
that begs the question why are there so
many ads for these courses the answer
it's an easy pitch to sell you a course
because if you think about it on the
outside it looks like a really good
business model to a beginner you get to
work from home there's zero startup cost
you only need a few clients to make ten
thousand dollars per month the client
pays for the ads so you have low
overhead once the ads are up and running
you don't really have to do much but
these of course creators that have
successful or somewhat successful
agencies know is the truth
running an agency kinda sucks trying to
get new clients with tons of competition
around kinda sucks getting clients
results kinda sucks
keeping up with policy and rule changes
in advertising platforms China sucks
trying to scale up to handle more
clients without laying the quality go
down kind of sucks
trying to keep clients happy really
sucks
so put yourself in their shoes if you
were in their position why put the extra
effort to scale your agency when you can
just make a course play on people's
desires to get rich quick conveniently
leave out all the downsides of social
media marketing agencies sell it for 997
with super high profit margins passively
through ads and live webinars and not
have any of the burdens that come with
dealing with clients when you look at it
this way it becomes pretty evident but
the money and ease is in teaching them
knowledge not putting the knowledge of
the practice so do I recommend you start
a social media marketing agency a
Facebook Ads
agency or whatever they decide to call
it in 2019 or 2020 or 20 21 or whenever
you watch this video no absolutely not
so what business should you start then
well you're probably not gonna like this
answer but I don't really know
listen everyone is different everyone
has different preferences and skills so
what I would think is a great business
model for me it could be a terrible one
for you for example I thought day
trading would be really good for me but
I didn't really enjoy it when I tried it
even though there's plenty of people
making very good consistent money with
it even if I could be consistent it's
just not something I see myself doing
long term so even though it may not be
the simple clean answer and you were
hoping for you kind of just have to try
a few different things to see which fits
you best that may sound like a pain but
I like to think of it like how often
college students switch majors which is
like all the time it's just a part of a
game when you're brand new to the space
and you don't know what you really want
to do yet one thing I do know for sure
is that the right business model for you
probably won't be running a social media
marketing
you see but who knows maybe I'm wrong
though so thank you so much for watching
you guys and if you enjoyed this video
style for the entrepreneur niche please
just click all the buttons down below
click the subscribe button click the
like button click the notification Bell
so YouTube notifies you whenever I
release new videos just like this one
these things help out the YouTube
algorithm tremendously so thank you in
advance and also I was thinking of ways
for you guys to monetarily support this
channel so I can keep making videos like
this because it does take up like a good
chunk of my day every single day but I
also didn't want to like shamelessly ask
for patreon money or like pushin 997
course on you so I came up with this
pretty seamless and effortless way for
you to support this channel if you want
to so down below you can open up my
Amazon homepage affiliate link and a new
tab and then you can bookmark it by
clicking the star icon on Chrome that
way whenever you feel like buying
something from Amazon you can click on
that link to take you to the Amazon home
page and whatever you buy I get like 30
cents if you get like a book or
something so that'll be linked below if
you want to support this channel if you
do thank you so much check out these
other videos on the screen that I am
confident you will enjoy thank you so
much for watching you been awesome I've
been Jake and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]
you